[Musique]
Il était une fois et il est encore
caché parmi les glaciers de
l'Antarctique une montagne creuse qui
d'après la légende garde le secret sur
les origines de l'homme
au cœur de cette montagne il y a une
caverne qui ressemble à l'intérieur
d'une coque de noix
et sur ses parois sont gravées de
symboles qui raconte l'histoire de
l'humanité
[Musique]
au centre de la caverne dans le plus
grand silence au d'une massive Table
Ronde taillé dans le rocher
c'est un lieu sacré
17 tables et ronde dans le Nord le but
de n'avoir ni première ni dernière place
car les êtres vivants sont tous égaux
devant Brahma le concepteur de notre
univers
[Musique]
Brahma est l'une des entités appartenant
à une civilisation Cosmic extrêmement
d'évoluer si avancée qu'elle échappe aux
limites de notre compréhension
nous la terrestre considérons ces
entités comme des divinités
puisque nous sommes trois parere pour
comprendre comment et pourquoi elles ont
conçu la réalité tangible et les étoiles
dans l'énergie permet la vie sur
certaines planètes des diverses univers
car il existe d'autres univers
composé eu aussi de milliards de
galaxies
d'étoiles et de planètes dans certaines
sont habités par d'autres êtres et
d'autres genre d'homme
mais dans notre univers
la conception de la matière vivante a
été confiée à Brahma
la légende raconte que Brama sommeillait
dans une dimension sans espace ni temps
quand soudainement
leçon de l'homme
prolonger et puis sans le réveiller en
sursaut
Brama savait que ce moment arriverait
mais encore confus il ne savait pas quoi
faire
alors son épouse
Saraswati qui est la divinité féminine
sur laquelle rien ne peut se réaliser
lui conseilla de garder le silence et
d'écouter
ainsi
immergé dans le son de l'homme Bram a
conçu l'ordre cosmique un ensemble de
loi physiques biologiques et éthiques
qui maintiennent la vie pour la durée
d'un cycle
renouvelable à l'infini appeler le jour
de Brahma
parmi tous les êtres déjà parfaitement
achevé qui apparurent comme par
enchantement dans notre univers
sur la planète Terre apparu l'homme une
créature dotée d'une conscience
éternelle qui l'accompagne dans toutes
ces vies et qui lui permet de parvenir
au summum de la connaissance
les symboles gravés dans cette montagne
creuse
très peu de mystique en ont la vision et
ils ont garde le secret
pourtant tous les croyants les actes et
les philosophes et les scientifiques du
monde entier se font fort de connaître
les origines de l'homme
certains pensent qu'il a été créé par
une divinité pour gouverner le monde
d'autres Neil intervention divine
expliquant que l'homme est un animal
parmi d'autres et que son apparition est
plus banalement dû à une évolution
naturelle
sinon fortuite
[Musique]
l'une des théories les plus anciennes
l'avais dit qu' on est en Inde il y a
plus de 5000 ans et elle est décrite
dans les 4 livres du Veda écrit en
sanskrit
les Veda affirme que chaque personne est
doté d'une conscience éternel et que
quand le port de cette personne meurt sa
conscience se réincarne dans le corps
d'un nouveau-né
les textes védiques site aussi les
avatars des divinités venu sur la terre
pour expliquer aux êtres humains le
fonctionnement de l'ordre cosmique et
comment améliorer sa propre vie en
s'appuyant sur les pouvoirs de la
spiritualité
[Musique]
une autre culture
tout aussi antique LA sumérienne
la différence entre les deux cultures
c'est que la védique se base sur des
textes connu j'ai étudié depuis 5000 ans
tandis que la sumérienne a été
découverte au 19e siècle et ses textes
gravés sur des tablettes en argile
nous sont connus et étudié que depuis
plus d'un siècle
la littérature sumérienne soutien que
des géants venue du ciel à bord de
machines volantes sont arrivés sur la
terre pour en exploiter les richesses
minières
leur équipage était composée de noble et
le subalterne et quand ces derniers
refusèrent de travailler dans les mines
les nobles les remplacer par des
primates africain qui l'améliorer
génétiquement jusqu'à les transformer en
une nouvelle espèce appelée homme le
terrasse
en d'autres termes si les géants
subalterne ne s'était pas révolté
l'homme ne serai jamais apparu
d'après la narration sumérienne des
astronautes géants vivaient des milliers
d'années
possède une technologie supérieure et
sur pour cela pris pour des divinités
par les premiers hommes qui était très
primitif
mais bien que flatté d'être considérés
comme des dieux les géants traiter les
hommes comme des esclaves
exiger l'obéissance absolue et tuer les
désobéissants
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que naquirent les notions de
châtiment divin et de religion
toutefois ayant des difficultés
respiratoires sur une planète qui
n'était pas la leur les géants furent
contraints de vivre sur les sommets des
montagnes où l'air est plus raréfier
mais ces lieux étaient difficilement
accessibles aux humains
alors les géants améliorer certains
hommes primitifs formante une ligne
d'homme supérieur les adamites et
construire des édifices très ou du
sommet lesquels il leur donner les
ordres à faire exécuter par les esclaves
puis-je ils formèrent les Premières
nations
éditeur aux adamites qui sont les
ancêtres les Sumériens les textes gravés
sur les tablettes
dans ces textes les géants décrivent
leur voyage dans le système solaire et
la production de l'homme fait à leur
propre image
les anciens texte égyptiens
des divinités ressemblantes au Dieu
sumérien qui ont créé les premiers
hommes
dans l'ancienne Grèce
2000 ans plus tard donc il y a 3000 ans
Homère et Hésiode site des divinités qui
ressemble beaucoup au sumérienne et qui
elle aussi ont créé le premier homme et
la première femme
un Dieu unique et si tu es par
Zarathoustra
un mystique de l'ancienne Perse qui
prêche la continuation de la vie humaine
dans le paradis ou dans l'enfer
cette idée est tout de suite partager
par le nez sans peuple hébraïque qui dès
lors embrasse la foi monothéiste
les textes de ces Brahic précédent cette
conversion raconte les mêmes fait que se
graver 2000 ans auparavant sur les
tablettes sumériennes et si tu donnes
des géants vénéré au Moyen-Orient qui
s'appelle Elohim
mais après l'avènement du monothéisme
ces textes sont ajuster pour compiler la
Bible hébraïque un livre sacré où l'on
soutient que l'unique Elohim créateur de
l'univers de la terre et de l'homme est
Yahvé le dieu guerrier des Hébreux
nous le savons pas si la divinité
sumérienne
indienne
grec
chinoise
et les autres divinités si tu es dans
les mythes du monde antique sont les
mêmes car elles se ressemblent beaucoup
mais ne se sont pas tout comporter de la
même façon
dans la vallée de l'Indus
la spiritualité
Moyen-Orient c'était la guerre
en Chine dominer la culture
et en Égypte le culte de l'au-delà
quatre siècles plus tard au Népal
Bouddha suis la tradition védique
soutenant que la vie n'a ni commencement
ni faim et que les personnes se
réincarne jusqu'à devenir des esprit
éternel exemptés de la souffrance
en Chine la hausse à une conception
cyclique de l'existence ou l'homme ne
naît pas puisque il existe depuis
toujours et que sa tâche est de revenir
à la phase initiale qu'il a généré
600 ans plus tard en Palestine l'hébreu
romain inspirateur du christianisme Paul
de Tarse
déclarer l'existence d'un nouveau Dieu
Jésus
homme et Dieu Jésus a été envoyé sur la
terre afin que par son sacrifice sur la
croix débute une nouvelle humanité basée
sur le pardon et l'amour divin
600 ans écoute encore et sous
l'influence de la culture voisine
hébraïque net en Arabie la religion
monothéiste de l'islam dont le Dieu
unique lui aussi créateur de l'univers
de la terre et de l'homme
ressemble beaucoup à y avait le dieu des
Hébreux
les divinités cité dans les divers
textes sacrés du monde sont pluriel mais
alors qu'il n'y a aucune évidence
historique sur leur existence
leur croyants les vénère se basant sur
leur propre perception intérieure et les
plus conservateurs utilise la violence
pour convertir ceux qui n'y crois pas
à partir du 18e siècle en raison des
atrocités
guerre de religion Inquisition perpétuer
par l'Église catholique
l'existence d'un Dieu spirituel est
contestée et en Europe n'est la théorie
matérialiste
cette théorie soutient que la création
de l'univers est dû à une explosion
originel
que la vie est née d'une combinaison
chimique fortuite
et que chaque être vivant est le produit
de l'évolution spontanée de l'être du
même ordre qui le précède
[Musique]
la théorie la plus fameuse et celle de
Darwin qui contourne en la question de
l'origine de la vie l'explique par
l'évolution d'une cellule primordiale
qui a ensuite forme et décors plus
complexe
toutefois Darwin lui-même admis que
cette théorie a du mal à s'appliquer à
l'homme
à vrai dire pour toutes les plantes et
les animaux de la terre le chaînon
manquant n'a jamais été trouvé
les doutes sur l'évolution darwinienne
surgissent également des études sur
certains organes tels que les yeux et
les ailes qui n'ont absolument pas
évolué puisqu'ils ont toujours été actif
depuis le début
le darwinisme est défendu principalement
par les Anglais
j'ai même anglais après avoir colonisé
les autres continents en nous traduis
les oeuvres littéraires les plus
importantes mais ce sont bien gardé de
les divulguer
surtout la littérature hindouiste
héritière de la védique
puisque ces révélations de nature
spiritualiste bouleverserait la culture
occidentale des Ormes est devenu de
matrice anglo-saxonne
matérialiste et scientiste
de fait on a constaté que les ancêtres
les Hindous maîtrisait toutes les
disciplines scientifiques bien avant les
Grecs considérés comme les pères du
savoir
il y a 5000 ans les textes védiques la
manipulation génétique les nombres est
le zéro ensuite copier par les Arabes
mentionner des machines volantes qui
parcouraient l'espace et soutenait
l'existence d'autres civilisations du
Maine qui ont précédé l'actuel
ces civilisations était doté de
technologie très supérieure à celle
d'aujourd'hui
leurs traces sont encore visibles dans
c'est énorme eu construction que nos
ingénieurs ne savent pas égaler
et tout cela relativise la primauté de
la culture occidentale
il semblerait bien que la civilisation
précédant la nôtre était globale et
pacifique avec une seule langue le
sanskrit à la base de plusieurs langues
perdu
la littérature védique explique de
manière détaillée qui existe d'autres
univers
leur Galaxy
des planètes habitées par d'autres
d'humanoide dont certains ont déjà
visité la terre
la conscience éternelle qui les anime et
les intelligences cosmiques qui sont à
la base de la création
[Musique]
les Veda site des calmants les
évolutions et les involution des univers
les apparitions et les disparitions de
masse
les dimensions parallèles
les effets quantique le temps non
linéaire et d'autres notions pour le
moins fascinante
[Musique]
l'une d'entre elles expliquent que les
cycle de chaque civilisation sont quatre
comme les âges de l'homme
l'enfance
la jeunesse
la maturité et la vieillesse
le premier cycle est la préhistoire
le deuxième est la protohistoire avec la
pension de l'écriture
et dans ces deux cycles règles et
divinité féminine avec la paix et la
recherche intérieure
dans le 3e et le 4e cycle au contraire
règle les dieux masculins et leurs armes
c'est la période des guerres comme le 4e
cycle dans lequel nous vivons
actuellement
et c'est aussi le décompte entre les
puissances du mal et celle du bien
avec le bien qui triomphe au dernier
instant et qui prépare le champ au
nouveau 4 cycle ou tu recommence à zéro
très importante pour les Veda et aussi
le régime végétarien fait de légumes
crus et de fruits
essentielle pour un juste équilibre
physique et mental et pour le respect de
la vie de nos frères animaux qui s'ils
sont produits et massacré en masse pour
les manger
empoisonne l'air et l'eau créant en
outre des maladies dégénératives des
mortels
[Musique]
en effet manger de la viande veut dire
assimilé une substance toxique que les
animaux sommes compris l'hiver dans leur
sang quand ils comprennent qu'ils vont
être clé
en cet instant de terreur une glande
secrète dans le sang de la victime cette
drogue dont les fait se poursuit dans
l'organisme de celui qui la gère agitant
son cœur et son esprit jusqu'à les faire
éclater
cela était connu par Pythagore et les
yeux Rudy de son époque qui était
végétarien et qui s'était appuyé sur la
spiritualité védique pour méditer en
toute tranquillité d'esprit à quel rang
se connaissances scientifiques et
initiatique qui les ont rendu fameux
dernières notions védique mais non des
moindres est la récitation de l'homme
qui permet au corps humain de
réinitialiser ses propres vibration
jusqu'à les rendre optimale
favorisant ainsi la vie de celui qui le
récite et de ceux qui le fréquente
au contraire le matérialisme occidentale
et la fois dans le dieu argent désormais
exporter dans le monde entier temps de
ta la décadence de l'humanité comme
l'affirme les scientifiques moderne et
après lesquels notre quotient
intellectuel est en régression
l'intelligence est définie comme la
capacité de raisonner sur les
difficultés et de les résoudre par des
actions concrètes
mais dans le 4e cycle c'est capacité son
délégué à l'intelligence artificielle
dont le but est de remplacer l'homme par
des robots reproduisant l'intelligence
humaine
et on appelle ça le progrès
enlever à l'homme ses capacités
intellectuelles Emmanuel c'est le rendre
stupide et c'est exactement ce qui se
passe
il reste à définir si cela est un déclin
naturel ou la volonté de quelqu'un qui
agit avec tous les moyens dont il
dispose pour que deviennent stupide ce
qu'il veut dominer
la question n'est pas banal pour ce
faire il n'y aurait même pas besoin de
divinité ou d'extraterrestres il
suffirait d'une élite d'homme riche et
sans scrupule qui est c'est velléité ou
auquel cela conviendrait
qui produit les
anciens Romains à qui cela profite t-il
sinon à ceux qui ont tout à gagner dans
cette affaire
l'histoire antique et l'histoire
actuelle sont plein de mauvaises
personnes qui ont conditionné la vie des
peuples pour s'enrichir
[Musique]
avec l'argent on peut faire beaucoup de
choses par exemple
prolonger la durée de sa propre vie
comme cela est déjà décrit dans les
anciens mythes puisque s'il est vrai que
le temps est cyclique tu reviens
aujourd'hui c'est quelques milliardaires
qui gouverne le monde concentrent leur
attention sur le transhumanisme qui
augmente les capacités physiques et
mentales jusqu'à supprimer la vieillesse
la leur bien entendu
sûrement pas celle du reste de
l'humanité qui ne peut se le permettre
[Musique]
la Bible aussi si tu une durée de vie
multicentenaire pour les patriarches de
la ligne adamites qui était peu nombreux
et très riches conserver une apparence
jeune jusqu'à la mort et leur femme qui
m'aime centenaire enfant tête avec
succès
d'après la Bible en Palestine à cette
époque il y avait il y avait qui comme
les autres Dieu sumérien
exigeait des sacrifices humains et
traiter les personnes comme des animaux
mets favoriser les adamites qui a le
retour considérer les gens normaux comme
des êtres inférieurs
il semble presque qu'aujourd'hui le
rapport entre les yeux extraterrestre
leur privilégiée et le reste de
l'humanité se répète
cette idée est actuelle car il y a
quelques mois la NASA a officiellement
reconnu son l'ombre d'un doute
l'existence des WAP phénomène
aérospatiaux non identifié auparavant
appelé ou faux
ce sont les objets volants capté par les
radars militaires et civils tandis qu'il
traverse le ciel et les os des mères à
des vitesses qui échappe aux lois
physiques connu et ce ne sont pas des
objets terrestres sinon leur base serait
facilement répertoriées par les
satellites qui espionne chaque
centimètre du monde
l'un des plus estimées directeur de
centre spatiaux israélien
que les États-Unis est l'état d'israel
sont depuis plusieurs années en contact
avec des extraterrestres déployés sur
Mars et sur la Lune
nous sommes dans la science-fiction
mais même les plus perspicaces
conquérants du passé comme Jules César
Charlemagne où Charles Quint
or est estimé comme science-fiction le
vol d'un avion sans parler de celui-là
missile sol-air ou d'un chanteuse
il reste que
extraterrestre ou pas
99 % de la population mondiale et
aujourd'hui a servi par le un pur sang
d'homme richissime qui ambitionne le
pouvoir total
pour ce faire ils doivent réduire au
silence les peuples héritiers des
anciennes grandes civilisations
les seuls qui ont les capacités
intellectuel et spirituel à s'opposer
classement a eu de par leur culture
ce n'est pas par hasard que l'Inde
l'Irak la Grèce l'Italie la France et la
Chine soit parmi tous les pays de la
terre les plus frapper par les actuels
dominateur anglo-saxon ennemis du
spiritualisme et défenseur de la théorie
matérialiste basé sur l'économie
le Sud continent indien a été envahi les
divisé en deux pays rendu très pauvre
l'Inde et le Pakistan tous les deux
berceau de la civilisation
spiritualiste védique
l'Irak a été détruit avec lui les traces
qui évoquent la première grande
civilisation humaine la sumérienne en
ridiculisant aussi le contenu de cette
tablette
la Grèce terre natale de la civilisation
européenne a été pillé est anéanti
l'Italie est devenu un laboratoire où
les listes globaliste tu est aussi loin
que le peu la possibilité de resserrer
les tôt car c'est ici que son et
l'Empire romain
l'humanisme
la Renaissance
et surtout la religion catholique et où
subsistent des cardinaux qui défendent
encore la vraie spiritualité chrétienne
ennemi du matérialisme
si l'Italie tombe la brèche s'ouvre et
l'expérimentation globale peut-être
considéré comme réussi
tout de suite après l'Italie ce sera le
tour de la France
puisque elle est l'héritière historique
des nouveautés culturel italienne et
elle est dangereuse car son peuple très
pragmatique et t'habituer à se rebeller
la Chine
berceau de la très ancienne civilisation
taoïste qui a tout d'abord été drogué
avec l'opium puis exploiter en tant que
main d'oeuvre sous-payé et maintenant
combattu car devenu trop riche
aujourd'hui la nouvelle coalition
anglo-saxonne composé par les États-Unis
le Royaume-Uni le Canada l'Australie et
la Nouvelle-Zélande
dirigent c'est bon atomique vers la
Chine
reste la Russie qui est une nation
chrétienne très croyante et riche en
carburant
mettre op tendu pour risquer d'être
envahi
les Anglo-Saxons sont suffisamment futé
pour ne pas commettre les mêmes erreurs
que Napoléon et Hitler alors il la
menace en armant les pays limitrophes
et la frappe avec l'embargo une mesure
administrative et militaire qui empêche
la libre circulation des biens et la
croissance économique
[Musique]
en somme notre 4e cycle ressemble à une
cohue infernal
la classe moyenne est en train de
disparaître
les pauvres augmente démesurément
la natalité est étouffé et avec elle le
développement nécessaire au maintien de
la société
les millions de jeunes africains sont
pousser en Europe
déstabilisant notre culture et la leur
le politiquement correct frappe de
manière ridicule la littérature
l'homosexualité est un laissez-passer
pour le succès
les lois constitutionnelles sont ignorés
et on tente progressivement d'effacer
les droits sociaux conquis par deux
siècles de lutte syndicale
c'est le chaos
joue comme le dirai les Veda c'est la
bataille finale entre les forces du mal
et celle du bien
[Musique]
comment tout cela va-t-il finir
l'histoire et l'art nous le 10
il est bien connu le tableau de Raphaël
où l'archange Michel
écrase la tête de Satan symbolisé par un
dragon
c'est également un fait que lorsque peu
de privilégier sont confrontés à un
peuple furieux ça finit toujours mal
comme cela a déjà été le cas avec la
Révolution française et toutes les
autres révolution du monde
[Musique]
pour sortir du chaos il existe cependant
d'autres voix
d'autres méthodes
Gandhi par exemple on se confiance à la
sagesse védique avec la non-violence à
persuader 300000000 d'indien à croiser
les bras
obligeant les Anglais à rentrer chez eux
Nelson Mandela a été enfermé en prison
pendant 30 ans
et il en est sorti fortifié grâce aux
études sur les Veda qui lui ont donné la
force de vaincre la ségrégation raciale
Martin Luther King a embrassé le védisme
pour obtenir la parité des droits des
afro-américains
et dans le passé tous les grands initiés
comme dans tes Alighieri Pic de la
Mirandole
Léonard de Vinci et Michel-Ange ont
suivi les principes fondamentaux de la
culture védique les représentants dans
leur œuvre
pour conclure
tous les êtres vivants du plus grand au
plus petit sont tous des créatures
infiniment complexe
impossible à maintenir en vie sans un
projet initial élaboré et cohérent
coquin scientifique dans la capacité de
faire
quelque chose d'infiniment supérieur la
pourtant fait et continue de le faire
admettre cela serait un point de départ
suffisant
la meilleure chose à faire serait
peut-être alors de redécouvrir le
pouvoir de l'ancien spiritualité védique
qui pour vaincre les difficultés de
l'existence
conseille le régime végétarien et la
récitation de l'homme dont la vibration
favorise l'entrée en contact avec
l'intelligence cosmique
essayer
et le monde redeviendra sans doute
meilleur